i had a wonderful experience being
directed by olivia how awkward was it
for you to do love scenes in uh don't
worry darling you got a couple right it
does feel vulnerable harry styles
reveals what it's like being directed by
girlfriend olivia wilde in their new
movie don't worry darling which features
his first ever on camera sex scenes
that's right that is right while
chatting with howard stern the singer
details his approach to acting i just
think of acting slightly differently
than i would imagine a lot of people
acting you're not you're not making the
movie you're playing like a small part
you just and you you can show up and do
your bit and you try and do your bit as
well as you possibly can as harry tells
it it was a great experience thanks to
his girlfriend being in the director's
chair but stopped short of talking about
their relationship it's the easiest
place to fall in love you fell in love
on a movie sir oh wow how to answer this
question i had a wonderful experience
being directed by olivia i think it's
something that obviously like acting is
kind of very uncomfortable at times i
think you have to you have to trust a
lot requires a lot of trust if you want
to give it everything and i think being
able to trust your director is is a gift
our life together
i could lose this
olivia pulls double duty on the movie
directing and acting in the
psychological thriller the one thing
they ask of us is to stay here
where it's safe howard being howard the
conversation turns to the movie's
intimate scenes and harry opens up about
filming those romantic moments how
awkward was it for you to do love scenes
and uh don't worry darling you got a
couple right is that embarrassing to you
no i don't think it is i think the most
important thing in that stuff again is
like trust and i you know it does feel
vulnerable i think like you know i'd
never kissed anyone on camera before and
it felt like
giving a part of myself away in some way
because
you know you do it and then you feel
like oh now now i feel like people know
how i kiss or something like it just
feels kind of incredibly vulnerable this
comes as ichi learns new details about
harry and olivia's romance that's the
dream amid harry's concert tour a source
tells e.t that the couple is quote
packing in as much quality time now as
possible before he hits the road again
the source adds quote they treat their
relationship with a lot of respect and
work on it like they would their careers
[Music]
you